hallo mein Name ist laserluca und ich
bin hier mal wieder mit
ja selfies sagen ja wir drehen heute
nämlich Lachen Challenge habe 375 80 so
vielen Videos
[Musik]
ja das heißt ich
an dein Aquarium brennt
ja ja
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
Lieblingsland
[Musik]
Barcelona Lieblingsland
Bulette
Duisburg gehört auch echt mit zu den
unschönsten Städten glaube ich
Deutschlands
beleidigt und man hat mir in die Eier
getreten aber ich bin nicht wütend weil
ich dafür bezahlt habe wenn es jemand
aus meiner Familie sieht das ist
natürlich nur Spaß vielleicht
so liebe Klassenkameraden heute
präsentiere ich und mein bruderherzt
euch was wieder eure Zähne passiert wenn
ihr eine längere Zeit eure Zähne nicht
putzt wohin gehst du ich wollte nicht
erklärt mein Bruder euch was mit euren
Zähne passiert wenn ihr eine längere
Zeit eure Ziele nicht putzt ja gut zu
okay ganz einfach riecht nach scheiße
und dann hat sich herausgestellt gehabt
da war Single okay knossi hatte die
schon besser gerissen Frau ruft an hallo
Baby hallo Schatz
quasi wenigstens hübsch nein also
wirklich ekler bin ich mir das so
anhören Mensch du bist die schönste ich
bin mir so froh dass ich dich dann dass
du mich da rausgeholt hast als du aus
dem beschnupperungsprozess jetzt ist das
interessant ich will gerne weiter hören
danke ciao bis später freue mich
kommt das was hinter uns haben wir ein
wenig Zeit war wenigstens
weißt du sowas
[Gelächter]
ist doch viel einfacher kann jemand
vielleicht ein Video von mir machen das
wäre echt cool also warte mal wo soll
ich drauf halten
mein Name ist Nani mein Bruder Steve er
ist mein Stiefbruder
wie heißt denn wie heißt denn deine Oma
wer ist denn deine Eltern vielleicht
meine Oma heißt leider tot
[Musik]
ich liebe sowas das meine Haare sind
einfach gefroren ich weiß nicht wie das
passiert ist
kalt war
ich hoffe das konnte jetzt helfen
nur in der Unterhose von der Schwester
von meinem Kumpel gerochen auf einmal
wurde der richtig sauer ich weiß halt
nicht ganz ob es war weil sie die
Unterhose nach anhatte oder weil die
ganze Familie dabei war
aber irgendwie war der Rest der
Beerdigung auch voll komisch
wir sitzen wieder mit einem Bein in
Gefängnis und
alle sind
[Musik]
endlich endlich
[Gelächter]
Jungfrau hatte ich keine Tattoos
so stark
[Musik]
Smash
wie heißt diese
dieses Beruf
mein Vater sagt jeden Tag so Ausbildung
ich glaube das ist gut
ey mittlerweile weiß ich ganz genau
[Musik]
dein Gesamtvermögen wird auf 1,3
Millionen Euro geschätzt stimmt das wie
wurden das erschätzt das ist ja lustig
wir kriegen unser Kratzer einfach nicht
raus
ja
also ich würde nie wieder
wenn ich wenn ich eine Frau kennen wäre
so dass in der Öffentlichkeit machen
wenn bei der nächsten Nachricht auf
keinen Fall nein also wenn das der Fall
wäre
Schatz Antwort
ich habe extra mit dem Video Film der
komplette Wald
voller Feuer hier hinten
wissen Sie was brennt mein Mann ich habe
Sodbrennen
Bella Pizza
Digger diese scheiß Handy ist so kotzen
hallo
[Musik]
8 Stunden gefühlt in einem Unterricht
sag ich mal im Herbst guck mal Leute bei
mir war immer erste Zeit so da kommt
Pause nach Hause ich war nicht mehr da
weil ich habe ich habe geraucht alle
danach ich konnte nicht mehr Schule
gehen ich dachte immer ich bin guck mal
sei mal leise
was soll ich erzählen ja guck mal ich
habe geraucht ich dachte mir alle wenn
schreiben
einmal rein ich muss direkt anfangen
vorzulesen aber wie mit diesem Schweine
danach das hat gesagt ich muss auf
Toilette ich bin ich habe meine Sachen
genau ich bin rausgegangen und immer so
passiert danach erste zweite Stunde
gegangen
eigentlich nicht mal acht Leute Leute
ein bisschen suchen aber